I'll thank you so much for your kind
introduction I'm very excited to be here
I had never been a heel before I knew
was beautiful but not this beautiful and
you organized these amazing sunny day
for me so I am really happy to be here
this title might be puzzling for
somebody so less that's how tweed is
planning it it really tries to deal with
two issues one of course is related to
the term secondary and coffees
well copies are considered to be
secondary kind of source with respect to
the original which is the primary source
on which we rely and so the issue is
whether many copies may in fact be a
primary source as the original that is
lost
the second issue has to do with
permanence now thoughts actions events
cannot be frozen in time they happen and
go but we can make them appear main over
time if we embed them in a document and
we can do it because we want to preserve
the memory of what happened or what we
told or because we just wish to
communicate them that is to make them
cross space not just time and when we do
that in fact we generate something that
does continue to be and sometimes we
want it to continue to be and that's why
we have memory stitute stoop reserve the
documentary memory of our time but
sometimes we really don't think about
the permanence of what we generate we
just generate it and then it is there
someplace
keeps being there and nobody's getting
rid of it so this is the involuntary
permanence of the many copies that we
are generating today so the this year's
what the subject of this lecture today
yes
if you think that this is an issue of
digital times it is not at the time of
classic ROM the records were written on
works right and they were taken through
underground tunnels from the offices to
the tabularium where they had to be
putting up in a very protected place
because of course everybody could tamper
with wax and then that many scribes
would make copies a multitude of copies
they were passed on for access to people
among these people
kakero who would transcribe them in his
writing so you see it's a never-ending
chain when it starts and it started then
and he continues now and we're still
finding copies of documents that were
supposed to have been destroyed so as we
talk about ROM ROM Allah most concepts
that control the way we deal with
documents come from Ramallah for example
documents preserve perpetual memory of
facts and acts to which they relate
authentication has to be based on
procedure on now the documents are
generated I used the deposit of a
document in a public place guarantees
their reliability as a testimony of the
actions that the document talks about
antiquity gives documents the highest
authority why because obviously they
were not generated for the uses we make
of them today so you can trust what they
say because they were not tailored to
say
what we want them to say today am broken
legitimate custody ensures document
authenticity of course by inference this
is the Justinian code we are built much
of it on the Justinian code but of
course this is a body of laws and laws
are made to be broken so the rule of law
was circumvented it's very easy to go
against to use those rules by for
example bringing the forgery to a public
repository and depositing in there and
automatically becomes transported so in
the 17th century a Benedictine Tangshan
Babuyan
in France developed a discipline called
diplomatics which means about records
and it basically demonstrated that you
can base the trustworthiness of
documents on the analysis of the process
of their genesis on therefore on their
structure and on the way they are
transmitted through time and space so
during those times there were many
judicial disputes on authenticity of
documents which were called bella
diplomatic diplomatic wars and they were
based on diplomatic methods because and
I quote now the Bishop of Venice at the
time Valdiserri Bonifacio who said it is
so much better to win by reason that by
force
so records of documents are so much
better than Navy yard's and weapons and
that's the way in which the law of
evidence at origin in the faculties of
law in Europe so by mid 18th century all
the faculties of law thought archival
science and diplomatics as forensic
disciplines that is in order to prove
the facts that the documents talked
about so then if you put together
archival concepts and diplomatic
concepts you get
years field of study that is called
archival diplomatics which analyzes
documents on their own as individual
items - diplomatics
and in context among all the documents
of which up to which they are related
and that's archival science ok now we
can use these science archival
diplomatics
come forward there are lots of seats
here we can we can use it
retrospectively that is in order to
understand what happened in the past or
to understand that identify the
documents of the past or we can use them
prospectively
didya is to design the systems that will
generate the records of the future so
once we understand what are the
essential elements of the documents on
which we can base our assessment of what
they are or whether they're trustworthy
etc we can embed those elements in the
systems that we design for the creation
of future documents so that's the way
archival diplomatic ceases you today
that's why you have Dungeness face there
right the two phases looking at the past
and looking at the future and there are
three specific areas that we deal with
in our title diplomatics you can see on
the left the concept of record so the
analysis of all manifestations of
records through time and form and
element in the middle the process of
creation of the documents through time
and on the right the trustworthiness now
we want to focus now on the
trustworthiness area for a moment or
more okay so trustworthiness really
consists of three concepts reliability
accuracy and authenticity which are
quite distinct so the reliability is the
trustworthiness of a document
a statement of fact that is as to its
content
it means you trust what the document
says how do you assess reliability
normally you base it on the competence
of the order for example if you have a
blueprint and the author is an engineer
you tend to trust it more than if the
author is the janitor of the building
right
so you see you it is again an inference
I trust the order I trust a document or
its content and the second element is to
control on the creation not everybody
can get into the system
not everybody can use that letterhead
not everybody can use that stamp and so
on
accuracy is the correctness and
precision of the content so it's really
the data we deemed the content and again
is based on the competence of the order
but in addition is based on control on
transmission because especially in the
digital environment when you transmit a
document from a system to another you
easily get notifications authenticity is
the thing we want to look at today in
particular is the trustworthiness of a
document that is what it says it is
which has being uncorrupted and
untampered with and we base it on two
very important factor on the identity of
the document and on its integrity
so what document on which type of
document we base it well we know from
diplomatics
that a document can have different
degrees of perfection and the degree of
perfection of a document determines its
authority so if you write a note without
signing yet it doesn't have much of an
authority but if you put 20 stamps on it
and as many signature and a gold seal
you get the impression that this
document is saying something really
important
so there are three state of transmission
of documents only three ways that a
document can be can be a draft which is
a document prepared for purposes of
correction it is meant to be prevailed
provisional it is meant to be temporary
it does not mean that it is not
important to an historian a draft may be
more important than actual original
document that was generated from it but
he simply means it was not meant to have
legal consequences it was not meant to
attest to facts it was meant in
preparation of something else okay then
you have the original and the original
as to AFTRA characteristics
primitiveness must be the first but it
must be the first that is complete so
completeness and must be able to reach
the purposes for which it wasn't
generated so why do I write there in
brackets of facts well because what do
you do when you have a document that is
the first and it is complete the one
that you put in a fax machine but is
unable to reach its purposes other than
by the creation of another document on
the other side right which is the one
that is effective but it's not complete
because it doesn't have the original
signature and it is not the first and
this is the reason why procedurally
we always required about the sender and
the recipient keep their own part
because together it is an original
separated they don't attach to anything
so and you know why because the received
document can prove that was sent by a
specific machine at a specific time it
can now prove who actually put it in a
machine number one and what was put in
the machine because I could fold three
documents together to compose something
and pass it through in their separator
so I don't know why say I never send it
there is no such a document with me so
especially when documents are
supposed to reach legal effects you
better keep it about side so the concept
of original traces through time when we
think about digital environment so many
people say oh there is no original
course there is original except it lasts
for a nanosecond because the original is
the document that is first received by
the intended recipient you open it you
look at it that's your original then you
save it by doing that you take it apart
and destroy it and then every time you
recall it you create a new one
it's a copy but the original exists even
if for a brief time now through the law
the legal systems involved the civil
system civil law system and the common
law system the original has always be
the best evidence so what happens when
we don't have an original okay
we often have lost originals and copies
are not just made for convenience so
that they can be accessed by many but
they can be made for legal purposes so
we have different kinds of copies and
what distinguishes them is the authority
that they have but also who generates
them so for example an authentic copy is
a copy that is declared to be authentic
that is conformed to the original by an
officer West that responsibility cannot
be you it has got to be a notary a
lawyer a professional it has to be
somebody else
a third-party okay so that's a not antic
copy it doesn't have to be identical as
long as the person of the clear set
autentic considers it to be essentially
the same okay then we have the facsimile
anybody can do a facsimile you can make
a facsimile for exhibition what is
typical of the facsimile is that the
medium on which the document is
is identical to the one of the original
it's not just the content the whole
thing is identical if you were not
actually announcing that this was not
the original you could anybody could
think that it is the original then there
is the copy in the form of the original
the copy in the form of the original is
a second original that is the same
person who as he showed the original
later on issues it again so that means
that it is not the first primitiveness
is missing but the other two qualities
are there which are completeness because
he's absolutely identical to the
original and effectiveness an imitative
copy is a copy that looks like the
original for real it has elements that
make you distinguish it from the
original a photocopy a photocopy is the
typical imitative copy a simple copy is
just a transcription it's when you just
sit there and copy document an insert is
the copy the transcription of a document
within another document for example when
you forward an image to somebody what is
inside is an insert so it's a document
container within another document an
inspects immerse instead as really the
same force as the original and
substitute original what is it when you
have this is very typical of all times
traditionally in all in all
jurisdictions for certain legal acts the
record is the act no record not so a
contract of land ownership you need the
record you lose the record you don't
have to land unless you have a system of
registry but that didn't exist in the
past okay or the emperor or the king
gives your benefit
the record is the benefit that gets in a
fire is gone or over time they just
crumble and as they crumble the owner
would go to an Audrey another Republic
or a lawyer and ask for any spec CMAs
so the notary public or lawyer looks at
the documents and transcribes it writing
I have seen videos or I have inspected
is pack CMAs the original document that
says so so so and so transcribes
completely signed set you can destroy
the original that is the most
traditional way through which the titles
of old families and cities etc have been
preserved over time then the other thing
that you have to look at when you look
at copy in addition to who issues it and
how much authority it is is also the
hierarchy of copies so you can copy from
an original you can copy from a first
copy you can copy from the tenth copy so
the possibility of error keeps growing
so if you were you know the monasteries
used to copy the text in order to make
them go through centuries because of
course paper and parchment and would
crumble and the include disappear so
that was the purpose but human error
keeps compounding itself over time so if
you have a second copy it has more
authority than if you have the tenth
copy of something so that is also one
thing that has to be looked at now in
the digital environment let's move away
those are the concept that are the
foundation of everything now we have to
confront what we are dealing with we are
digitized originals which as originals
where on other media and we have no
problem with them that corresponds
pretty much to an authentic copy you
digitize it and you declare
that it is conformed to the original in
all the aspects the matter that is
everything but the medium but all the
rest is as if it were the original so
there is no problem there born digital
originals we already said exist for a
nanosecond so what are we dealing with
we deal with synchronic copies that is
copies made all at the same time for
example when you send a message to 20
people at the same time we're dealing
with your chronic copies for example
when you save them to an external drive
or when you make after the time you
regularly copy something for redundancy
so that you are sure that if something
is destroyed you still have neither
somewhere or for distribution to a
variety of repository the logs system
lots of copies make stuff safe that's
log system one thing we have learned is
that all the copies made through
redundancy and distribution are never
identical to each other if anything at
least the metadata related to time has
changed okay
never identical the other thing we learn
is you cannot preserve digital documents
you can only preserve the ability to
reproduce them or to recreate them and
we will see the difference later on
however in order to reproduce or
recreate a document you have travel
document in the first place right that
is you need to wear fixed form and
stable content what is a document with
fixed form in the digital environment
okay this is a type is a digital entity
whose binary content is stored in such a
way that what you see on the screen
every time you recall it is identical to
what you had seen before okay that is
the documentary presentation
Maine's constant even if the
technological or digital presentation
changes so you can move a document from
words to PDF is a different digital
format but what you see on the screen is
to say okay so that T is a document we
fix form but also a document as fixed
form if the same content can be
presented on the screen
in several different ways but in a
limited number of possibilities so the
same store identity can show up in
different form for example statistical
data can be viewed as a pie chart a bar
chart or a table but it is a limited
number and it is always the same
possibilities and the same data stable
content means that the data and the
message it conveys are unchanged and
unchangeable so the data cannot be
overwritten altered deleted or additive
or it means that the changes are limited
and controlled by fixed rules so that
the same query generates the same
outcome and we have different views of
different subsets of content for example
a library catalog an archival inventory
you never see it all together right you
do a query and you see the entry that
you want but the same query always will
get you to say response okay so that is
still considered fix stable content now
when we think about the document in the
digital environment in terms of XT and
stability and authenticity etc we have
to think of three parts not just one
it's not just this item that you pick up
it's three things that live quite
separately from each other one is the
formal elements of the document which
are the traditional ones we see on the
face of the document
the date the address the salutation etc
the other one is the metadata which are
the attributes of the document now the
metadata are not an invention of the
digital environment okay
we always add metadata we didn't call
them metadata we call the string seek
elements of the document there is ting
carve some old document fold it right
like docket style you fold it and you
put it like on the back on the dorsum
there is an endorsement right which as
the date of the document the name of the
addressee the name of who is keeping the
document the subject of the document
those of the metadata on the front of
the document what do we write when we
receive it the date of receipt what do
we write what we affixed a little stamp
with the name of the office receiving it
those are all the metadata the same
metadata are needed and are present in
the digital records except that they're
not they are transparent to the user you
don't see them on the paper you do
digital components digital components
are those torrid entities that are what
you actually preserve or conserve in the
digital world you don't see them and
they do not correspond to the part of
the document so for example if you have
10 memos that are all in the same format
and are all textual they can all be in
one component one digital component but
if you have an email with attachments
and digital signature you have the
header the message the attachment and
the digital signal there are five
components they go in five different
parts of the system and need a different
reservation measure so you understand
that here you're dealing at
completely different level with
different parts that eventually to
reproduce the document so that you see
on the screen have to get all together
because what we never add before is the
difference between a storage document
and a manifested document so in fact
with the digital entity we have at least
two documents every single time the
storage document is made up of the
components used in reproducing the
document that is in producing it again
when you recall it and they are the data
to be processed in order to show the
document which are content data and form
data the rules for processing them which
are the composition data that's all the
storage document the manifested document
is the visualization in a form that is
suitable for reading to a person or to
assist them now sometimes you don't have
this manifestation for example you go to
the ATM to get money right you put your
card in there and something happens
within the system that is the system is
checking whether you've got the money
and then decides to give you some and
then makes all the calculations
subtracts your money from what you had
every single action generates storage
records that is content data form data
in composition data that the system sees
but you will never see what you get is
the receipt idea okay so you can in
other cases you do not have a storage
manifested document okay but you can
recreate it like in a relational
database so when you have a relational
database and you ask a query a document
show
up you can decide to save it as such as
what you actually see in which case you
have a manifested document you have a
storied document or you don't say that
because you know that every time you
want to see it you just go through the
same query so in that case you recreate
the document every time you see you're
not reproducing you're recreating it
types of digital documents two types
static the ones that all allow you to
open close and navigate and nothing else
and interactive they're variable content
form etc but the rules are fixed that is
whatever you do always you get the same
output okay so in light of old above
when we talk about digital copies what
you need to do is to identify the
authoritative copy because we have
millions of that and the best way of
identifying them there are other ways
that I will mentioned but the best way
is to look at the metadata which are the
primary means of provide authority to
copy or to identify the authority of a
copy okay identity metadata definition
identity metadata are all the attributes
of a document that characterize it as
unique altogether they make it unique
it's like you know your identity card it
says where you're born when you were
born you know and and all that where you
live
etc so all those elements they make up
that your card this is the same thing
identity metadata are unique together
for each document and these are the ones
that we call identity metadata the names
of the person that concur to the
creation of that document the dates
times of Genesis issuing and
transmission measure or subject
relationships form name format
presentation
attachments and if applicable a digital
signature you actually don't need
anything more in fact we were saying
today a lunch that really all you need
is the expression of the relationship to
other documents because once you
identify that then you can go to all the
rest you can access everything else you
have the classification code like a
person is an ID that's it that's the
person from there I can go anywhere so
this idea of having has metadata for
under 25 attributes it's really not only
no realistic but not needed integrity a
document that's integrity if the message
it is meant to communicate to achieve
its purpose has not changed you see the
message needed to communicate has not
changed what are there well okay so we
have traditionally said we infer
integrity from the fact that we trust
whoever is keeping the record so you go
you you deduce integrity from
responsibility and you say if I know the
names of the persons that endl the
document over time if I know is
responsible for keeping the record if
there are are notations related to
changes about technical changes and any
other kind if there is a digital
signature etcetera if I have these
elements then I can say I can infer
integrity which is the quality of being
complete and unaltered in all essential
respect and we have never been fussy
about it right so if you add a document
with a hole in the middle or yellowish
or with a [ __ ] fading away all with the
corners burned you wouldn't say oh it
has lost integrity so we don't want it
it's no longer authentic if it tastes
good enough right as long as I know what
it is well it's that different in the
digital environment
let's see loss of integrity of an analog
document you still read it still managed
still okay I still have the same
document don't you now digital document
if the original beats are 1 1 it is a 5
if it is 1 1 0 it is a 6
if it is 0 1 1 it is a 3 same beats
different value why because the order
counts not just the number so you can
see that we're not talking about fading
away we're talking about losing bits we
lose the record because we are talking
about data integrity based on bitwise
integrity the fact that they are not
modified intentionally or accidentally
the beats are in a complete and an
altered state so a small change in the
beats means a different value on the
screen or a different action how do we
protect them well intentional alteration
is preventable through permission and
access control access privileges or to
checksum in our Shagari
accidental alteration is preventable
through special art wear and software
but the problem is that we have to be
able to determine that alteration has
happened most of the times we don't
really know and so what do we do do we
go and check the logs yes on a regular
way we could but in fact we have to
infer integrity till such time when it
is questioning and then you have the
logs to control it otherwise there is no
other way and as regards copies because
we live in a copy world in a world of
copies duplication integrity is
important it's the process so given a
document a digital document you must be
sure that the process of copying it
doesn't change it and often
dears change is linked to time that is
today wouldn't but tomorrow avoid the
process that you carry out because
depends on what else is in the system so
and of course we do duplication all the
time but not necessarily the output is
the same when we talk about a copy we
talk about a selective duplicate a
selective duplicate is never the same as
the original because you can only copy
what you can see and on paper it was
very easy because you could see the
metadata you can see the metadata in in
the digital environment or other things
like that metadata there is rarely
confirmation of completeness and there
is an incomplete picture of the
environment the image is a forensic
duplication is a bit by bit reproduction
of everything but you may not want to
have that sort of duplication to deal
with because then you would have to
maintain it all those parts like swap
space lock space ambient data etc that
are useless you don't want to so how do
you have an authentic duplication well
you have an authentic duplication when
in some way you can maintain a native
format now over time we have been used
to PDF right for delivering page based
documents we use for preservation PDF a
because it allows to maintain all the
fonts PDF a to increases accessibility
but PDF a tree is where we're heading
now because what it does is to provide
you the service of PDF a1 that is you
see the document as as it shows
permanently on the screen but it can
embed all the previous formats so it is
what is used now to address the issues
of obsolescence
and of readability and usability and it
gives you the main display document in a
stable infects way and the metadata set
can be stored in the Dom data sections
to assure authenticity so any concern
about best evidence and data integrity
can be addressed
embedding the bitstream of the source
within this document so these years what
now is considered to be the copy that is
appropriate mostly against obsolescence
and for the purposes of best evidence in
a court of law and the process through
which we do it must follow the principle
of non-interference which means that the
metal do you use is not changing
anything or the principle of
identifiable interference if it is
changing anything you say what it is you
can identify it I don't think we have
the time to talk about digital signature
I have five minutes so you have the time
so so there is a difference between
authenticity and authentication that is
key because authenticity is a quality of
the document either result and occur it
is it okay authentication is a
declaration that the document is
authentic in that specific moment but
not necessarily the next day okay so
today we use digital signature for
authentication and digit signature is
not a signature it is a seal because it
is an attachment to a complete document
that already has its own signature or
whatever needs to web is complete as is
it verifies the origin of the document
certifies the intactness of the document
it makes authorship and ownership
indisputable that is no reputation okay
so
the digital signature talking about
copies is said to provide
incontrovertible mechanism for verifying
authenticity of digital object right
accept what it is that it verifies that
the person who claims to have sent a
document is in fact the person who
claims oh yes right and it verifies that
the document that was put into the
system and sand has not been altered it
does not verify that the copy is
actually a copy of the document it
claims to be so we are back to the same
thing all this mechanical system they
just prove you that what you receive is
what was sent by the person but that
person is sending you the copy of the
document that she or he is claiming to
be something that you can do certainly
not with the digital signature
besides digital signature are good for
ensuring authenticity of document as
they move across space from a system to
another now the cross time because it
becomes obsolete before the documents to
which it is attached and cannot really
be preserved and memory stitute ins are
not maintaining them so what's better to
use while a chain of legitimate custody
is ground for inferring authenticity the
digital chain of custody is the list of
all that has been done to the record for
the document from beginning to end and
the Declaration on the trustworthiness
of the system within which the document
exists so especially the courts now
saying well if I can trust that nobody
has interfered with the system so I will
believe that the document in the system
are ok is an inference again so we get
to the main slide here involuntary
secondary permanence where so now by now
you know we have already lost track of
everything the copies are uncontrollable
they are everywhere they are distributed
they read on
there there are lots of other indicator
copies for preservation etc and we don't
really want to keep them and we don't
know where to find them in order to
destroy them so we give up that's the
situation except it's not much of a
problem if we have an announced system
if everything is inside our building and
our servers were only clogs the system
but really it's not such a problem but
what if the documents are not with us
what if the documents are in the custody
of some cloud provider of some other
third party how do we prove the
trustworthiness of the copies that they
have and they control that's why we
created the fourth phase of interference
in the Paris trust or I trust so this is
the fourth phase of the research project
its goal is to generate theoretical and
methodological frameworks to support the
development of networks of policies
procedures regulation standards and
legislation concerning digital documents
and Trust to the Internet it is funded
for five years it includes about 300
partners from six continent in 35
countries and this is in order to ensure
that whatever we generate is consistent
across and the reason is that the
documentary memory of the world is
increasingly in the cloud because
archives and libraries have to acquire
material that already exists in the
cloud and they have to provide access
from everywhere to anybody the systems
that are acquired by ISIL are not
affordable the knowledge required to
deal with this material is not
affordable
many believe that protection equals
preservation which is not true but under
this illusion this is what they do but
mostly we are confronted with a
generational change
we're the younger people past 1981 they
integrate public and private they
co-author things there is crowdsourcing
there is coning sharing working from
home bringing your own device to work
and material ease on a variety of clouds
convergence of media if I tell you that
I will meet your five o'clock I send you
a Google map right I don't give you an
address cost and connectivity liquid
communication an enormous amount of
ephemeral material generator
what is its characteristics they can be
viewed differently based on choice of
browser application user preferences so
it is impossible to say which one is the
authoritative version unless you have
the torah derivation in your renal
system metadata may be constructed by
anybody to manipulate the behavior of
the system not just to describe it if
the goal is communication you have a
specific way of having the document to
self-destruct but if you don't do that
nobody is going to destroy them when
google promised to eliminate with the
international court right you know the
verdict to eliminate all the documents
related to a specific situation
he cut the links it didn't we eliminate
the documents the documents are there so
if you use a different search rather
than the name of the person you search
copyright in a specific kind of articles
you find all the articles again so
everything is there it will never go
away so never put up there anything you
don't want to be used against your
grandchildren in the next 100 years so
if the goal is memory now people create
their own digital archives out of you
know documents taken from everywhere so
the primary challenges very quickly are
the reuse the creation of derivative
works
the sharing movement of material from
one circle of people to another
constantly numerable copies employees
collectively create bodies of
interlinked material Government of
Canada wikipedia 150 Department 250,000
employees create documents together and
so nobody knows to which agency each
document belongs and one has been
completed or generated location
independence so the jurisdiction of the
entity responsible for preservation is
different from the jurisdiction of the
entity responsible for storage and so in
voluntary permanence is rising to a
whole other level
you know what the cloud is so we don't
need to say the issues obviously our
transparency ownership authorship
creatorship retention and disposition
loss of context trustworthiness
jurisdiction and addicts so
traditionally we deal with this with
policy training model agreements but
that's not enough we need much more
because many or any copy can only
replace an original by having the
authority and the effectiveness of an
original and we don't know that any of
these does so stay tuned